what up guys welcome to the just
brilliant youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels give me a break before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell the way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos all right let's talk
to the fbi
come on in old school we haven't done
one of these in a minute
we've done one of these in a minute for
good reason why the shows are monday the
shows are monday through friday tuesday
and thursday on the ground but today has
been a day that i think i just need we
just need to talk
we need to talk um you guys see the
title of this little impromptu
call give me a break give me a break
um and before i get into this um
here in atlanta it's a little overcast
today uh i spent the day
yeah i still got the bmw glad you
mentioned that uh actually went out test
driving i'm looking at a new car
cia competent intelligent and assertive
three things that men need to be to
become the better version of themselves
fbi feminine beautiful inspirational
things that three things that women need
to become to become the better version
of themselves but today i did go out and
uh
i'm starting the process of looking at
new looking new vehicles
so uh when i decide on what i'm gonna do
if i'm gonna do something
stay tuned but anyway give me a break
look man give me a break
i was born with a father who was out
doing what he was doing i was rolling
stone
you know god bless his soul you know my
mother did the best she could what we
had you know my story is like anybody
else's story
um functions of poverty
you know issues from childhood i'm not
any i'm not special
i'm not special any more special than
anybody else the difference is
you got to give yourself a break man
give yourself a break give me a break
you got to break these cycles so many of
us
did not get what we needed in childhood
did not get what we needed in our uh
our formative years uh did not get what
we needed when we decided to go to
college and relationships and this and
that and bottom line is this
you're not following my content because
you don't want something and the thing
you want is likely
being the better version of yourself you
know i tell people you attract what you
are
and you hate and you hate the things you
are it's because i've sat there and
had to do that that work that intensive
work and uncomfortable work the work
that comes along with having to be
vulnerable in front of a therapist in
front of a counselor
yeah this is what i say you reap what
you sow i'm gonna let him go because
he's spitting facts right now but
it's true you reap what you said talk it
out
to understand that you bring you to
every situation that you're in and
if you don't do the work i could drop
you in the middle of the situation you
say you want i could drop a woman in a
room with a hundred high-value men
wanting to get married in under a year
and they blew it
conversely i could drop a hundred being
in a room full of feminine beautiful
inspirational women
wanting to be cooperative and submissive
to a man and you would blow it because
you haven't given it
because you can't give yourself a break
how many of you guys have really decided
to do the work to break these cycles
meaning tonight saturday night how many
are going to do the same thing you're
doing all the time you can go out with
your girlfriends
and and go to the same spot same club
same thing with the same outcome don't
go out at home or do the same thing or
you're gonna sit at home and do nothing
why don't you give yourself a break
yo i'm telling you like two years ago
i made the decision that i was going to
move cities
and stop drinking and it was going to be
easier to stop drinking because i put
myself in a new environment where i was
wouldn't be tempted by that
and i wasn't gonna come back to illinois
um
until i felt like i had a handle and i
wasn't tempted to go out drinking every
weekend
and i'm telling you it's been like two
three years since i've made that
decision and
i'm not going to pretend like i've been
100 perfect there have been times where
i drank too much but like
overall when i see like where i am today
i know i would not be here if i was
doing the things that i used to do
why don't you do something different why
don't you go ahead and break the cycle
and become the man you want to be become
the woman you want to go by yourself
remember when i said you have to do it
scared of doing afraid do it alone
do it unsure without a guarantee only
you can guarantee is your effort
that's why i say that real high value
men and women appreciate one thing about
people more than anything else they try
they try they try they don't make
excuses they don't make excuse they
don't
they don't accept the problems my mom
didn't do this my last relationship
didn't do that this didn't that didn't
happen all that shit's over
today today is all you having to do with
and what are you doing with it
and so many of us got our head down in
the sand stuck thinking about the future
or the past not in the present give
yourself a break
give yourself a break today and say i'm
going to be present i'm going to get out
of my house today and i'm going to go
sit somewhere around human beings and be
present in the moment
talking about stuff that's in the moment
not worrying about the future not
worrying about the past
not worrying about a bill not worried
about this be present and you'd be
amazed at what you could get out of
relationships out of people
in the world because with all this
communication potential we have
we got we are the most communicated
non-communicative people we ever had we
got more ways to communicate and people
still can't communicate
because you're not present then you run
up on somebody who is present in the
moment and it scares you you're like oh
[ __ ] this is new what they made eye
contact they smile they shook my hand
come on man give yourself a break
gentlemen
break the cycle do something you know
about you do step to that woman who's
you find attractive forget all the red
pill this peel that pill showing
interest how bad it is
carry on somebody in a conversation
she's human that [ __ ] sneak just like
yours ladies when a man walks up to you
stop acting like your asses up on your
shoulders you know he steps to you
because he's attracted to you he wants
to see if he can raise your interest
enough to have a relationship possibly
sex why we act like we know what's going
on because we haven't given ourselves a
break we still playing these roles
playing these games
no this is what i
i totally agree with because when i see
the red pill and like the
um black whatever like whatever pill it
is
um i see a lot of really frustrated men
and a lot of times it doesn't offer
solutions that i think
are super useful so to speak
um but yeah i'm gonna keep going like a
bunch of [ __ ] robots on autopilot for
self-destruct
and then you look around the people who
seem to be having a higher quality of
life better outcome
because they're deciding to break it up
break it up
you don't have to be perfect you just
have to try you don't have to get it
right you just gotta try oh my god my
dad says this to me
all the time like because
when i was growing up this isn't even
about dating but when i was growing up
like i would always
tell my dad like i i was not that smart
in school like honestly um i think i had
maybe like a 3.0 i guess a b average not
bad
but i had siblings that were all just
like smarter than me and i always felt
like i was the dumb one
and my dad always told me that i was
going to make it further
than people that are just naturally
gifted because i try and i work hard
and at the time i said dad that's easy
for you to say you're smart and
my dad is he's one of the smartest
people i've ever met but
it's crazy how true that was and it's
kind of the same thing what he's saying
with dating my
dad doesn't really do dating advice he
met his wife at like 22.
and i will tell you this if you decide
to give yourself a break if you decide
to try what scares you
if you decide to try what you fear what
you failed at you will sleep the sleep
of the just tonight because at least
you'll say
i tried i didn't win i tried yeah versus
living a life of regret that is the one
thing i refuse to do in my life
i will fail i will fail i will fail i
will fail i will fail i will fail but i
will not regret
i will risk i will fail i will risk i
will try but i will not regret
because when you are taking your final
breaths you're not worried about
anything other than
did i make the most out of this life or
do i have a life full of regrets and
fears and things i didn't try [ __ ]
that no regrets no fear
ladies stop living life on fear mode
make yourself a vulnerable make yourself
vulnerable to the kind of men you say
you want
gentlemen stop living life on fear mode
make yourself available to the kind of
outcomes you want
give me a break give yourself a break
today peace out
yeah how many views did this get
oh my gosh that's only in a couple days
no i think that's actually a very wise
uh piece of advice
because that's all you can really do in
life is try
and like outcomes are never promised the
world doesn't really owe you anything
but if you try your hardest it's like
crazy what can happen i mean it's crazy
when i think of my dad like
he's someone that tries harder than
anyone i know
and you know he's 50 something
he's probably in the top half a
percentage in terms of wealth
built a huge huge company has 10 kids
like it's crazy because i literally
think about this sometimes how crazy
the stuff my dad and my mom have
accomplished together
like i'm i'm so lucky to have that as an
example
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree don't forget
to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell and i will
talk to you guys next time